liebe leute die wir freunde liebe es
hieß es willkommen zu einem neuen video
das ich mich gigantisch vor was aber
höchstwahrscheinlich auch meinen ruf
ruinieren wird denn ich habe mir den
treffer von max aus gewinnen an der
steller max du was wirklich glaube ich
einer der ersten in deutschland die das
gemacht hat und wenn sie heute einige
videos reinziehen bei denen es sehr
schwer ist in gewisse bereiche nicht
zuschauen und wir gucken mal wie gut ich
ganz gesund halte davon nichts gehört
der masse gemacht ist der verfolgung
warum meine augen sich hinbewegen seit
gestern auf dem bildschirm an und sorgt
dafür dass ich mich heftig beim ihre ich
glaube gar nicht lange um leute fangen
wir an mit katja okay ihr wird es erst
wieder von katja kein klick heiße
rollenspiele mit fremden mann ich wollte
das auch full screen und dann können wir
loslegen
[Musik]
von der steckdose und versicherung
muster steht das bisschen gemein leute
es ist wissen gemacht aber das war es
auch dazu sagen ich hab ja meist ein
einziger videos auf youtube sind
tatsächlich von jungs von männern wenn
man das gleiche mit frauen machen würde
ich glaube ich würde das genauso
ausfallen aber es geht für mich und um
durch katja auch in kontakt zu lassen
auch in kontakt rollenspieler und das
hat schon so oft geholfen bei
freundinnen und auch bei mir selber ich
finde das einfach mega geil
auch wenn man es selbst hat was hilft
einfach mega wie lange das ist fakt ist
er also ohne scheiß ohne scheiß bevor
irgendjemand jetzt dieses video sieht
und sagt du folgst passt die was man dir
bewusst glaubt mir leute ist es nicht so
reicht das ist nicht so leicht außerdem
ist es ja per se auch keine schlechte
idee sich auf die relevanten dinge in
dem video zu konzentrieren jetzt wird
irgendwann sagen europa sind bastian von
oberflächlich von dir aber ich glaube
katja du mir bei der ausreise zu stellen
schauen wir uns mal korrigiert
ja ich bin aber rasch
der erste kontakt ich schaue in deine
augen märz werde ich schwach
ich hoffe aus und ich will es jetzt ich
bin stimmung also wirklich leute es ist
unfair es ist tatsächlich unfair weil
das gesamte augenmerk kameraführung und
der ganzen szene liegt ist mit dem
verlauf dinge auf die man nicht schauen
soll man sieht okay gut genug von katja
genug von katja doch die leute wie es
gibt mir jetzt cassia und machen bei
einer anderen youtube in weiter die
ebenfalls weg hat ja dafür bekannt ist
eine der prominentesten und
intelligentesten literaturkritikerin in
deutschland zu sein
die rede ist von musik super
eine meinung die todesstrafe das läuft
ganz gut also wir sehen hier diverse
einrichtungsgegenstände von höchstem
interesse für mich wenn wir auch einen
äußerst interessanten heizungsregler
meine lustigkeit schritt und eine grüne
lampe
gerne mehr davon bei der hoffmann hat
sich etwas geändert wenn ihr diese
haarfarbe feiert dann schreib dir
einfach mal schon gleich am anfang
direkt in die kommentare wenn ihr sie
nicht freiheit und weil der alte hafen
sie zurückhaben möchten aber hey leute
ich mag nicht gut oder also ich wieder
einige videos geschaut aber ich glaube
das geht schon klar oder
dann schreib dir einfach versteckt war
wie in die kommentare
ich bin sehr gespannt auf dem feld oder
wisst ihr was leute ich hab gehört
ich habe gehört natürlich nur ich habe
hier habe ich mal von einem einem
älteren reisenden mittelalter basis
das ist scheinbar auch videos von uci
kat und katja zusammen
okay das jetzt doppelt schwierig und
dachten uns nächstes jahr will und
selbst etwas kann eben passieren leute
das ging aber tendenziell jetzt wieder
eigentlich ganz gut so also was haben
wir pantomime challenge mit kaffeekasse
widget lässt überhaupt nichts mehr geht
einfach überhaupt nicht optimal so
konnte
ich bin so ein ich bin so ein fucking
treuer gläubiger enthaltsame christ
heute geht durch so was den augenkontakt
wie sie möchte von allen guten geistern
verlassen
heute also es ist es geht halt ich's
klar solange man sich wirklich aktiv
darauf konzentriert dass man der
personen die augen schaut oder sonst
wohin schaut aber nicht daher schaut
weil wir dabei die konzentration ein
bisschen nachlassen lässt und dann die
augen schweifen lässt ist man sofort
sofort fällig bei kletterausflug in
altötting geht hier zu ende fielen
dadurch schon vielen dateien youtube ist
dämonisiert die drüben fehlte noch ein
für euch persönlich vorgeschlagen das
video chat ist auf jeden fall ab und
schaltet machen wieder einmal gut ich
kann